but those are the norms democrats go out
they harvest ballots we know that they
do that we have motor voter laws
people who are not eligible to vote
sneak in they vote anyway we know that
they stuff the ballot boxes i don't know
if they did in this election
maybe they did we know they have many
years past
those are the norms and then they win
and now with universal mailings they're
going to keep counting the votes until
they win
in just about every election now when
you break those liberal norms when you
go back to more of the constitutional
norms turns out we win
you can see this in house races from
2020.
according to the cook political report
listed 27 house races as toss-ups 27
they didn't know which way was going to
go on election night how many of those
do you think republicans won
what do you think 10 maybe i don't know
we were told it's blue waves they
probably should have won zero right no
how many they went 10 15 18 20.
27 that's how many they won all of them
the polling firms
oh it's a toss-up it's not a toss-up
republicans won all of them
they went in and they fought burgess
owens
you all know burgess owens he just won a
hotly contested race
in utah he was trailing the incumbent by
11 in final polling
and the non-partisan cook political
report
called it a toss-up and then he won
this system that we were told that's
constantly pumping propaganda
to to support itself is
separated from reality talk about truth
decay
okay it's uh we were talking yesterday
about alternate universes it is an
alternate universe
and that is the permanent state and when
it when
a state such as that when elites such as
that becomes
so self-serving you you saw it in in
newsom's apologies you see in jack
dorsey's apology when they're just
out helping themselves disappearing
rules people start to distrust the
system actually regardless of your
ideological view left or right or
partisan
you start to see that system cracking up
that is what's happening right now
that's not the people's fault that's the
fault of the people running the system
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you